well we spoke to William Pomerance a
Russia expert at the Wilson Center in
Washington I think they want to express
the President Putin that the US and the
EU want to see the full implementation
of the Mint's two agreements and that
begins with a ceasefire in eastern
Ukraine there has been increased
fighting over the past week in eastern
Ukraine and therefore I think the
message to President Putin is you need
to rein in the separatists and the
forces you control in eastern Ukraine
enforce the ceasefire and then we can
begin to address the full implementation
of the rest of the Mint's provisions the
sanctions have been very effective for a
variety of reasons they've addressed the
ability of Russia to attract foreign
investment particularly in the energy
sector that has been sharply restricted
under the sanctions it also has limited
Russia's ability to have access to
Western findings that also has
essentially been closed off to Russian
state banks and other government
institutions so the sanctions have had a
very profound effect on the Russian
economy they are not the only reason why
the Russian economy is struggling right
now you can also point to the falling
price of oil inflation a declining ruble
a host of other factors structural
problems within the Russian economy that
have also contributed to the economic
crisis that Putin is currently facing
but the sanctions play at an important
role in that crisis as well primarily
not only because it cuts off access to
Western markets but it creates
significant uncertainty for people who
are even contemplating investing in the
Russian Federation there's a vote coming
up at the end of June and in order to
kind of contribute to the sense of
urgency of the need to maintain these
sanctions I think President Obama has
turned to a slightly more aggressive
language William Palmer ends